hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation what
may be the final episode in this amazing
series and I'm finally back from my
little vacation but we have a bit of a
problem we have an objective that is
almost impossible for me because I don't
almost don't know what I'm doing and I
have no other supplies oh I do have a
noisemaker I did not know that I've
picked up enough supplies to be able to
do that because I'm gonna be very very
nearly up to my neck in alien spotting
Frawley well that ain't good do you oh
you might know you might know oh he
doesn't know
oh what a dum-dum I was standing right
in front of him then I must have been
panicking way too much to be able to not
handle this hey buddy don't worry about
me that sounds like he's about to worry
about me I need to go restart the
generator which is a very bad thing to
do well that ain't good
that directly above my head they're
about to be an alien bastards it's about
land square on my head
okey-dokey sure love the sounds of
screaming in the distance it's awfully
comforting in my time of need
haha please wait your butt okay so well
something it was about time and I need
to get all the way from point A through
here up there around that way maybe take
that little root in there but either way
I'm gonna be dead I'm gonna be so dead
whoa Nelly Warren Miller who's there
what do you know
where is he oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
oh this sure is good oh my god hey there
was something over there you should
check it out maybe yeah so weird that
that thing that that is huh he just
wants to come near me
he just wants to hold me close I'm sorry
I'm I'm a little busy I need to get the
hell out of here you need to stop
worrying about me like it what was in
there
no no no one noise maker left yeah I've
got just enough to flamethrower to be
able to make him not kill me right away
it's very useful I just need to be very
careful about what I'm doing here I need
to be the most careful I've ever been in
my life please just don't kill me don't
kill me please have run out he ran away
okay there's my one goddamn chance if I
can just get to that goddamn save point
if I could just get in there jam it in
right all that data right that sexy data
okay it did it I wrote the data I'm good
kind of oh that ain't good baby's back
whose sensor I'll take that yes please I
don't know what I'm doing oh god this is
about to be noisy well looks like this
is about time where I'm gonna do but I
can make one more of these oh that was
horrible all those the worst oh why am I
so terrible at life well I might as well
make another one before I die horribly
hopefully if this goes wrong I got that
save over there that's gonna allow me to
go back and not screw up ever
hello oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's uh
that's good
maybe this bolt gun is actually gonna be
some kind of useful in the face of that
monstrosity
but then again I'm gonna go with maybe
not please tell me you won uh he's still
hanging around here
hey you should do something else what is
that what does that do no come on stop
hanging around there why can't I have
anything else to throw like a frickin
bottle or something I would make this
game almost too easy yeah maybe you want
to go through the doorway again and stop
hanging around here like a goober oh yes
yes exactly that don't turn around
cuz that would be ridiculous oh he turns
around oh god you know I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna fight the ball on this
one
huggles all around thank you alright
that was stupid because of the way I
threw it it was supposed to go farther
than that but it didn't it did not feel
they just quickly but oh oh that's right
a sensor that's what gave me that so
he's gonna be hanging around here for a
little bit being all fun oh wait and
he's not in here he's not in here yet oh
he's on its way but he's not in here
just yet I might be able to just do this
Oh give it to me
Oh give it to me so good oh give it to
me restart that oh yes I'm not trying to
make everything sexual here I'm just I'm
in a very emotional state
so this is making me making me very much
interested in I don't know oh he's not
coming through there
where's he at
go through there I should go through
there that'd be a good idea I heard
something from behind me
better not be climbing through these
sons of [ __ ] I got noisemakers yeah
that's an awfully disturbing sound it's
all I got
it's all I got baby you wanna know is
maybe I got noisemaker baby okay that's
right okay so I'm gonna put a noisemaker
right through that gap save save save
it's the smart technic good so the
generator has been restarted and I'm on
my way to victory honestly I don't know
what I'm gonna do after this because
this is probably the hardest this game
is gonna be don't don't
wherever I go ah goddamn it oh god those
a Hail Mary I don't know if that's what
I needed to do or not but I'm out of
here
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know all I know is that I'm moles
there oh I've got one long-ass whole way
oh it's so long oh come on I can't crawl
any faster can I go we could pop out I
know he's body's coming
oh god I'm so dead I'm sorry that who's
gonna there's no way it's gonna work no
way no way oh my god give you that
delicious save let me crunch my data
into you let me slam my card into your
port okay perfect
I know they put these here just for this
reason cuz they knew that it was gonna
be a bit stressful to be able to go back
and forth I really hope that there isn't
a code that I'm supposed to remember
[Music]
what the hell I gotta do maybe I should
have been aware that I was in broad
daylight and he was looking through a
window okay so this time honk it cuz I
gotta save it's right there
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go come on come on come
on
I'm gonna go around this way so that he
doesn't see me immediately after he
lands where those whoo hey whoa hey whoa
now whoa now now that you don't know I'm
here you don't know nothing fine fine
everything's fine
did I get any flying sir no not a lick
of flame thrower fuel because that would
make my life way too easy
[Music]
where am I gonna go I need to find an
offering root too little if you believe
me go to the okay thanks of the Torrens
but why don't you just worry about me
and not worry about anybody else because
if you start trying to save people
that's when people are gonna die you
know that to be true so I'll just save
me and don't don't worry about nothing
that why does Ripley have a southern
accent all of a sudden while Wallace is
happening under stressful situations my
Midwestern Cincinnati
southern accent comes out y'all know
what I'm talking about
y'all know what I'm talking about
getting their mind Ridley's got to get
out of here where's the goddamn set oh
yes yes oh please tell me I'm out of
that neck of the woods now because I do
not want to deal with any part of that
up again I'd rather not cuz I have
literally nothing to my name anymore I'm
gonna have one noisemaker that's it yuk
yuk
I can't make anything else can i nope
I'm done
so I also I know that I have not been
smart and I haven't been using my actual
like hammer to be able to hit walls and
distract him because there is a delay
I'll actually run towards the noise he
or she whatever it is oh wait a minute
this look familiar
wait a minute isn't this where I started
where am I going actually I guess I'm
just going down for now
why is everything on fire why does
everything need to be on fire but this
is towards the beginning of the game I
remember this I remember this so either
one of those is gonna be Bakht up wait
what's that one no no no no wait for my
synthetic emergency warden why would I
do that okay so those are locked I'm
assuming that the alien is not around
here so I can run freely just at least
for a little bit cuz I mean so that's
all cooped up that's not okay what's
over here what do you got for me
ion torch baby I got the power the will
and the drive here we go boo that's
right
come on I know there's aliens around I
know there's hundreds of aliens around
why did I even think that I was three
there was literally hundreds of a little
family all underneath my feet that is a
weird thing like for a long time there I
didn't think that anything was wrong oh
god I gotta know the blueprint that a
lot of good that's gonna do
[Music]
this mission packet sent from the edge
of leaders before ship started a trip
home nothing's going to break anything
[Applause]
it sounds like you broke something okay
good good
Oh goddamn it I just did that well what
was the point of that was that supposed
to help me anyway I got more
flamethrower shut up
ah come on I get out of my ears I don't
need you right now
I just had an intimate moment with a lot
of save points I don't need your Oh okay
I get it over here ah
I did not see I assume this was the
locked one also actually I may have run
into this leg here back in the beginning
of the game and notice that it needed an
iron to it that's actually cool because
then you see the points that you needed
the technology for or the upgrades that
you need it's a way in advance of
getting them so I guess that's kind of
but either way I am out of here I am so
out of here apparently yes we're gonna
go free and nothing is gonna go wrong
because that happens free the torrents I
don't know if I needed to go in that
room for anything other than just
getting those messages maybe but other
than that I don't really know so here we
go
Todd I don't know what's going on here
okay do I run now I'm gonna say first
way before you tell me to start hurrying
I'm gonna take my sweet time I'm gonna
army crawl my way to here
goddamn [ __ ] whatever do I need a suit
okay no I do not okay
God you son of a [ __ ] gonna get no just
no I knew that was gonna be a mess out
of the corner of my eye way before it
grabbed my leg why don't you hustle with
the goddamn it
your primary directive of keeping it
safe it's no longer instinct how do i
unlock it wait a min okay so I need to
unlock oh okay so those are gonna be
actually in the vent systems that would
that's it yeah they're in the central
ones so I need to go in the center ones
and then up and back like oh god you
didn't tell me okay okay did not know
that did not know that did not know that
did not know that did not know that
okay so now that that little heart
attack is over I can actually get back
to work
sense or I'm looking for a dr. Adel
clamp which is gonna be straight ahead
apparently oh wait a minute are they
above me did I go under here for no
reason I'm guessing I did but Lisa's
gonna keep me relatively distant from
the dude these weren't here before are
they here now okay come on come on come
on pack it away oh yes oh my god I'm
great okay and done and done
so that one's out so I can take the fans
get out of here why do why do they
provide me with so much scrap it's not
like I'm ever gonna need it yeah I say
that guys though that's a dead body
I wonder what exactly happened to that
dude
notice on time and let's see if he has
any is he smiling whoa whoa that's a
little creepy there huh
he toned the creep back down a bit okay
so where's the dude I don't know where
the dude is where's the thing where's
the thing should be right here
anywhere near here to be right on top of
me store power straw power we gotta do
smashes is okay so store power the power
goes down there there's got to be a way
to restore power down there the wires
going through here maybe that's what
this guy was doing before he smiled
himself to death oh okay so back down
here I thought about going here first
but I didn't think that it would have
been prudent but apparently it's exactly
what is needed that's shaking better not
be nothing
kachunk got stupid 1980s power systems
all being stupid and one not failing it
every goddamn opportunity eating regular
fuses all over the place it was just a
throwaway lever
I think the machines could do that they
weren't all dead no aliens please no no
come on easy one yes I shall I shall do
exactly that
just one longer than an alien nearby I
think I'll be fine
Oh hit the sound of an alien that was
the sound of an alien wasn't it yeah the
music has gotten interesting and make
anything else while I'm here mala stop
perfect that's exactly what I need to
kill myself huh nope maybe I should just
not waste the alcohol and just drink
myself to death right off the bat old
gun Amal found a lot of good the both
guns doing me we're fine
let's do this let's do it let's do it
let's do it come on come on come on huh
there we go whoa that's a torrents out
there we're control rum why you got me
running around doing everything to
platform dock control I think extend the
ability personally I think I need to go
up these stairs over here
was unpleasant no no no no no you're a
trap you're a trick see trap I'm going
so slowly we orbital sibylla's I don't
know if this is the way this is not the
correct way
that's the incorrect way where's the
correct way I guess I just need to go
straight up that way because that's what
it's saying go grab me go grab a
all right nothing lulling me into a
false sense of security I really wish I
could save oh yeah this feels safe nice
and safe oh yeah I feel so good about
this decision walking out in the open
where nothing could possibly rip my guts
out through my teeth okay okay you load
my bolt gun my useful bolt gun I really
don't know if my bolt gun can do
anything
also it's really weird because my bolt
gun doesn't seem to have any sound to it
neither does my weapon maybe that's cuz
I'm sneaking and it's trying to be a
little stealthy for me which I greatly
appreciate well this looks fun
I seem to be ascending in hell at the
moment why once again why is everything
on fire
why is this okay is this okay this
doesn't seem okay I'm not gonna get off
of here alive am i nearby but I still am
assuming that I need to be relatively
quiet so I don't summon the alien to my
current location because that's usually
how this goes oh man where'd your face
go bro I'll just take that you don't
need that right
whoa wait I think I can use the
maintenance rig instead yeah no that
doesn't seem good all wait that's what
it means I'm gonna be getting a student
that that the the actual thing it's not
good I would remove the umbilical that's
like the docking thing that people can
walk along such that they would not die
we just grab some things please don't go
down do they they don't
let's not screw it up now did I just
hear a blip on my motion sensor I did
didn't I
nice and calm about this wait a minute
hey did not see you there buddy how you
doing how you doing there friend Oh what
do I do about this make another Molotov
okay editor quitting time
okay where do you know I got my
flamethrower I got plenty of
flamethrower fuel not plenty not enough
to be spraying it willy-nilly all over
the walls like some other douche did
before me but just enough to survive
just enough to be able to get away at
least three times at most three times
yeah go investigate whatever new okey
that's more than one there's more than
one very good
I'm gonna take the option of going down
underground
this is probably where they all are we
didn't hear a damn thing
there's more than one I'm so boner owned
[Music]
thank you
he's gonna lead right to it right noises
noises in the darkness go check it out
good good good good good good good good
good good good good
give me my flamethrower baby I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
it I'm gonna make it I am going to make
it well have I bet I don't have enough
time to change into this in privacy
Palin's gonna come in and see ripley
naked can't have none of that a little
bit of expeditions missus that's a bad
noise know what felt like that was
supposed to happen
what's going on no salmon salmon whoa
that ain't good
oh that's exactly bad they're trying to
build another nest in a hurry I don't
think they realize that this is all
going to hell Oh struggle
yeah Ripley you got it oh yeah yeah good
job that's gross
how do they make all that stuff so
quickly that person said oh [ __ ] oh god
I gotta get back do I have all my stuff
I do Wow hey you know what I ain't gonna
ask out because push these suckers ain't
gonna sneak up on me if I don't go
[ __ ] about the I don't go [ __ ]
about the flamethrower it actually does
last a little bit because now I'm gonna
wait till I get more materials because I
actually have molotovs which are going
to be mighty useful nah yeah I follow is
gonna be away from this no no yes bupkis
you die with that terrible death you
freaky spider scorpion weirdo the
nightmare of HR Giger shalt nots consume
my flesh get your dagger venom was that
where where who asked
I think you gonna sneak up on me huh
ain't good sound that bad sound alright
who's that
where am I now where the hell am i how
am I supposed to get all the way over
there it's that's obviously a no-no and
there's gonna be a lot of little things
I am saved
I've not saved exactly Nazi I know why
are you giving me all this fuel pop out
of me yet yeah that's what you get for
not taking away my weapons maybe you
didn't think there were weapons fire
good alien kid come get fire fire keep
you warm in dark space
here you here you a just normal
squigglies
what you gonna do what the hell well
that's not normal behavior boy
I totally just realized now that we're
on some sort of a decommissioned tram
here I say decommissioned
I meant totally destroyed its ass went
out its front end yeah why are they
building their nest on fire nananana
I said no why did they not kill me it
looked right at me am I already in fact
oh god I'm good
I'm already infected aren't I
oh no that's how it's supposed to happen
oh no oh no oh no oh no that's bad oh
this is convenient
oh no oh no maybe maybe not I don't know
get up search hello wherever you are
some 80s person
okay what do I get I need to reload my
flamethrower fuel I need to make
whatever things I can say never know
what I'm gonna be able to make another
one always make her good I did not get a
lot of stuff I need to heal I need to
make another bed kid I need to heal this
is my little bit of break here everybody
calm down I have not saved I want to
coach this very commonly confidently
that's like batteries come on come on
come on back here we go do this I don't
know all that was the plip on my motion
Raider hear about noises in the darkness
I got enough flares I never actually see
I never actually really used the flare
as much but I imagine the flare would
keep an alien relatively at bay like the
flamethrower would but maybe it wouldn't
no I believe that was a train are they
gonna come barreling down oh you son of
[ __ ] ain't you
oh I gotta play hopscotch with this
I am not saved
is there no safe way you kidding me
right you kidding me with this [ __ ]
oh come on
do I go or don't why wait there's
another one you gotta wake up where's my
root where do I go yeah oh come on what
do I do
okay alright okay so I
oh okay I'm going for it just bear with
me a little bit I can't die okay there
we go there we go okay okay
okay all right how okay there's no way a
train's coming through here it's all
blocked up yeah hot burn okay I'm okay
oh is that okay what does this mean yeah
no kidding you script it son of a [ __ ]
just give me a heart attack
yeah you cause I know I was there
I usually scrunched my head down those
fellows the oculus rift now would have
been really disturbing okay so I'm just
gonna guess it's not gonna be total dick
not gonna try to kill me ow
Bernie it points
what's going on oh don't tell me as soon
as I start climbing
let me another train
this is just messin with me now you just
want to throw things at me yeah heavy
breathe kind of get oxygen to that thing
groaning your belly not a baby
it's an alien baby not a good baby
that's a bad baby oh I thought I saw
something oh I did see something okay I
just gotta make it to that doorway
totally fine right yeah stop making
weird noises okay okay okay where the
hell are we
the maintenance office goddamn it
oh that's full of eggs that's uh that's
got an egg in it yes please with the
flamethrower fuel oh god that's the only
way I gotta go god you son of a [ __ ]
you're doing this on purpose gave me a
bunch of save points before
I hear you I know you're in there
what happens if I throw like a flare in
huh
okay I'm taking this very slowly guys I
know I knew it
we're yet
oh yeah yeah yeah I heard you I won't
take any chances
yeah okay where am I going let's go get
through here let's get around in there
sorry yeah did you go for me right that
move I'll throw a freaking Molotov in
there I don't care I thought I was dead
I thought it was dunzo thought it was
done Ian rings don't be dick bag there
you go
that's right that's right I'm the king
of this jungle
it's my time to shine
did I get them all
it's gonna be one more isn't there last
one
yeah this looks precarious fine fine
fine fine yes please hold on to
something
what does that do I didn't do nothing
are you talking about
oh okay well okay I got a quick think
it's gonna go god it's gonna god hold on
just hold on is that thing's gonna fall
off they said yeah cause we're goddamn
Nicholas this is what this is
god damn
that's a lot of bad noises I don't know
if they mean some damn it
all right oh I can go down I didn't know
I could go down all sorry everybody I'm
I'm a [ __ ] hi hi I thought oh it's just
supposed to hang on there until
everything just went to [ __ ] okay what
else could go wrong what else okay save
semantics I just died
I fell over and died
are you kidding me with that [ __ ]
are you kidding me we smear by
come at me pros
okay all right we're moving forward I
just fell over and died from I'm
guessing the fire that was there oh that
was fun
God that gave me such a heart attack I
thought I was gonna be sent back so far
they huh they're so good I've never seen
an autosave in this whole game that's
the only place I've seen an autosave
just frankly they would be the face of
my god no scarier than anything like
just that
okay forgot about you
here we go for real this time okay
sounds bad okay you've let it oh you
haven't let anyone else that oh I can't
save there oh good glad at least my
suits still here when I found fall into
the same goddamn trap I did before
what's wrong with the other suit never
didn't want change over the goddamn vent
above my head alright so now we're back
on track I'm oh man I was about to lose
my mind if that was gonna oh god I'd
been so careful up into that point oh
man I almost went so slow everyone out
there was probably mad at me but frankly
we're going into space and I'm happy
about that
space called my god space and it's the
porins
I get to release some explosive bolts
thank God I took that detour
oh good glad to know we're fighting the
gravity of a giant gas giant that's just
a regular one a giant one all right what
am I gonna do
avoid stay at a space depress and then
do what exactly I wasn't paying
attention all it's very concerned about
different situation Avenue I am slow I'm
going about the same speed as I would if
I was crawling so good to know this
consistent pace through the whole game
oh boy I saw I gotta go all the way over
there and I got to release some
umbilical things or whatnot well that
looks bad something big just hit that
one if some big Sun hit me hopefully not
so I need to go a long way down
oh good there's a cart for me I bet this
is gonna be filled with a lot of drama
like the most stress inducing I've ever
had in my life that's gonna duck for
safety okay it's also bred a we're gonna
go to space so badly all the space okay
then excuse me
burn me don't need you anymore okay yes
ascending the lighted stairs hey I got
nothing really to say at this point look
at that so pretty not even look at how
big that is like understanding this
still probably millions of miles away
from where we are just to get down to
the surface of the planet that's nuts
freakin nuts maybe not millions maybe
not millions hundreds of thousands
definitely
whoa okay
Brian the release mechanisms
okay I'll prime it up how do I do that
oh I gotta go down here okay key card
we're gonna get a key card oh I got a
key card add get the key card from this
then put the key card in there okay
that's one down well that's an alien
that is definitely an alien why is there
an alien over there who's not too sure
of what he's doing
whoa that is cool oh I wish that time to
taking all the scenery this is beautiful
whoa what just happened over there
something went wrong yeah good so cool I
wish I had time to stop and appreciate
all the coolness cool of course I am
pushing random his buttons made all the
lights turn on okay activate that Johnny
I'm just gonna ignore the aliens out
there for now
this is some weird-ass bomb mouki then
what the hell that was a very weird bomb
damn do I got do to all these I gotta
hurry it up that doesn't sound good it
is still very weird back in this so
that's good
there still feel like there's aliens
looking homes around me this is
intentional this is intentional they do
everything intentionally in this stupid
thing they're doing Italy they're
intentionally making this a forever very
tedious bomb well I know I saw an alien
that's intentional okay
come up to present just president
[Music]
and a service to pay
all the people aboard
[Music]
I highly doubt you'd be able to see that
because if this is still a gas giant
that's like that explosion would be the
size of like three Earth's that depends
on the size of the gas time but it's
jupiter-sized yeah oh my god how did it
my way up to the bridge Verlaine Oh No
Verlaine oh look it's the torrents green
buttons Oh buddy bump into boo
woo what is this for can I get in here I
need to check myself before I wreck okay
well then I don't know how I did that or
why okay Verlaine Verlaine I got a bad
feeling again cuz I always have a bad
few that change or am I intentionally
staying in my cereal you're being very
slow meticulous agent Purvis
transana
I don't know this
[Music]
what
oh I'm assuming that light was her being
picked up kind of like the inception
ending when you don't know it's just
about to fall over oh she's just about
to pick up or be waking up oh man so she
wasn't infected
maybe I mean obviously in the storyline
I think it's casually mentioned her
outcome you can watch the movies if you
wanna see it obviously if you've seen
the movies already than you already know
but like oh oh god oh god it's been so
long since I did a long let's play where
I actually thoroughly enjoyed it from
start to finish
there was so many moments route so
frustrated with everything that was
happening I was just like oh I can't
believe I can't gosh so frustrating but
god damn it was worth it I wouldn't I
would rather have that alien be as tough
and as smart as he was the whole game
which he was and he got worse which is
fantastic because that makes it a
challenge and that makes it always seem
like I can never win and it did
oh it's like there was some truly truly
heart-pounding moments throughout this
whole thing and it wasn't just like it
wasn't just like you know oh it's an
unstoppable monster was like I am going
to die there is impossible this to this
aspect of it and I can't do it so it was
fantastic it was so good oh such a good
game oh good game I don't know if
they're planning to do more with Ripley
there but oh oh
hundred out of hundred ten out of ten
one out of 100
my god okay so with all that expounding
that I do have some flaws with the game
that I would like to point out because I
mean it's a great game I had so much fun
playing it but there are also things
about it that need to be addressed one
inconsistent pacing
I mean pacing is great in horror game
basing is fantastic in a horror game but
there was so many throughout this entire
long 14-hour game it's a very long game
especially for a horror game it's hard
to keep someone's attention for that
long so there were points of peaks and
valleys and then there were points of
just sustained stress throughout an
entire long stretch of time and I mean
it's good to have variety but at the
same time it was very similar throughout
the whole way but still stressful which
kind of made it more frustrating in some
aspects than it needed to be now this is
just minor minor critiques about the
game there's nothing wrong as and the
game as a whole the story was really
cool if a bit predictable what I heard
some okay I'm gonna wait till the end of
the credits but I'm just gonna finish
what I'm saying right now
um just it was a little bit predictable
in sometimes maybe that's just cuz I
know aliens me heard that maybe just cuz
I know aliens I've watched every single
movie I've looked into a lot of it I
played all their games you know I know I
know aliens I know aliens very much I'm
a big fan of the series and that may be
why on it and that may be why I'm katika
but stop that I'm trying to listen okay
but either way it's just this game was
fantastic it's the first amazing alien
game in a long time if not ever like I
don't know if there's ever been a truly
fantastic alien game an alien isolation
takes the cake from what I've played so
far now I don't know I'm not an expert
in the gaming field I just watch the
movies a lot but still really good
through and through top to bottom I
enjoyed and I really hope that you guys
enjoyed it I want to know what you think
in the description below obviously about
this game those of you who have been
with me from the start
those of you who have been watching for
so long I really want to know what you
think of this game
what is flaws what its main points love
greatness are like I think the alien
literally the alien itself was the
greatest thing about this game that the
the androids were creepy at first and
then they just got really annoying and
tedious but the alien through and
through stop that I I'm trying to listen
the alien through and through was my
favorite part about this game and it
should be it's an alien alien video game
it's about the aliens the mystery of the
aliens the threat of the aliens thinking
that you have no escape and no way to
fight back you literally can't kill this
thing like the in the first movie and it
was great I mean if if a bit you know
like it made sense for the story for the
daughter to be after mother find out
what happened but to put you know the
daughter in the same situation was good
either ironic or fantastic I don't know
you guys can be the judge but really let
me know in the comments below what you
think of this game I'll let me know in
the comments if you're now a fan of the
alien series and if you're going to go
watch all the movies now because they
are pretty good there's some that you
could skip on just watch the first two
and then just keep there if you still
like it just keep going tell anyone I'm
gonna wait till the end of this credits
to see if there's anything at the bottom
so wait patiently with me everybody
oh no okay so there was apparently
nothing at the end of the credits well
so I guess the teaser was already put in
there but just thank you all so much for
joining me this is probably the longest
game I have played on YouTube I mean I
did 14 parts of it and only three or
fourth I think three of those were 30
minutes the rest were hour-long parts I
mean The Last of Us was long but I think
this one actually is longer so either
way just thank you all so much for
watching thank you all so much for
sticking with me for this long I'm gonna
finish up the evil within - I don't know
if I'm gonna go to hour-long episodes
there but if I need to wrap it up
quickly I hope to get to the end of that
game but alien isolation this was truly
truly a spectacular game I will remember
this for a long time I almost wish I
could have played it by my
self without talking because that would
have made me more immersed in it so if
you're on the fence about playing this
game there's some more playability I
believe that I'm not gonna get to maybe
I'll get to I don't know but there's
downloadable content coming to Survivor
mode which is I guess is just surviving
long scan from the alien but oh boy
alright so anyway thank you again
everybody for watching click the
annotations or look in the description
for other big let's plays that I've done
check out my dead space series nightmare
house blah blah blah old stuff that I've
done for a long time there's a lot of
fun stuff out there so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video how about
you go [ __ ] yourself buddy oh do I get
to do something your house fall on a
pile of bodies if I get one good one man
one bullet
wah-bah still not by myself with this
don't go Justin zombies